honestly  pharrell is a vibe to be in the studio  with like to soak up  if like anyone that's ever been in a  studio with pharrell to soak up from him  and to see his process  like he'll you'll learn some [ __ ] like  so  yeah pharrell i think is uh you know  there's a few guys that i think every  artist has like on their checklist to  work with it's like dr dre  pharrell yeah he's he's like that like  i would just watch him like wow like did  you learn a lot that you replied to your  own creative process from being around  him so much  absolutely like if something don't feel  right i get off of it like you know  like i don't sit there and try to write  a line for like  10 hours like if it doesn't feel right  it's like move on let's move on like  let's move on and come back to it  because  it should be natural it should feel good  it shouldn't feel like homework